"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
AMERICA, ARE YOU READY FOR
JOE BIDEN'S BIG COMEBACK?
WELL, YOU BETTER BE, BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA CLAIM
THAT JOE BIDEN IS GOING IF HE
TURN HIS FAILED PRESIDENCY
AROUND AND FOLLOW IN THE
FOOTSTEPS OF RONALD REAGAN
INSTEAD OF JIMMY CARTER.
SO HOW IS JOE GOING TO DO IT?
DEMOCRATS ARE RUSHING TO JAM
THROUGH A $433 BILLION CLIMATE
AND SOCIAL SPENDING BILL AFTER
GETTING THE GREEN LIGHT FROM
JOE MANCHIN.
PROMISING THE BILL WILL NOT
RAISE TAXES OR MAKE RECORD
INFLATION EVEN WORSE.
>> LAST YEAR YOU SAID THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, THE COVID
RELIEF BILL WOULD NOT CAUSE
INFLATION.
SO WHY SHOULD AMERICANS BELIEVE
YOU NOW AND YOU SAY THIS NEW
BILL WILL NOT EXACERBATE
INFLATION?
>> I MADE SURE THAT I DON'T MAKE
THAT MISTAKE AGAIN, THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE.
IT DOES NOT RAISE TAXES AND I
HAVE SAID THIS BEFORE ALL WE DID
WAS CAUSE LOOPHOLES.
>> THIS IS A RED, WHITE, AND
BLUE BILL, HONEST TO GOD.
>> Jesse: A NEW STUDY SAYS
THAT IT WILL RAISE TAXES ON
THOSE NOT MAKING $400,000 A
YEAR, BUT THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
IT WILL GET BY.
>> THAT IS INCORRECT.
>> SO THE JOINT TAXATION WHICH
YOU GUYS HERALDED AS AN
EFFECTIVE VALUE WHEN YOU ARE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE IS NOT TO
BE TRUSTED HERE?
>> I SAID IT IS NOT CORRECT
BECAUSE IT WILL BE INCOMPLETE.
>> Jesse: REPUBLICANS SLAMMING
THE SPENDING PLAN EVEN SAYING
JOE MANCHIN HAS BEEN TRICKED BY
THE LEFT.
>> IN THIS TIME OF A RECESSION,
THIS TIME OF HIGH COST OF LIVING
IS NOT THE TIME TO TINKER WITH
THE TAX CODE IN A WAY THAT I
CANNOT SEE ANYTHING BUT BAD NEWS
COMING FROM IT.
>> ALL OF THE SPENDING IS
UNNECESSARY ABLE EXACERBATE
INFLATION.
I LIKE JOE VERY MUCH BUT I THINK
HE GOT TAKEN TO THE CLEANERS.
>> INFLATION GETS WORSE, THE
EXPERTS LOOKING AT IT, BELIEVE
THAT THE INFLATION WILL GET
WORSE AND IF THIS IS FALSE
ADVERTISING BY THE DEMOCRATS
AT --
>> THEY SAY AND GROW THE
ECONOMY, LIKE I SAY THEY WILL BE
SAVING MONEY AND NOW IT IS
REALLY GOING TO DESTROY OUR
ECONOMY.
>> Jesse: CAN YOU FEEL THE
EXCITEMENT IN THE AIR?
JOE BIDEN TURNING HIS PRESIDENCY
AROUND?
>> Greg: IT SO BAD THAT YOU
SEE OUR NATION'S POLITICIANS
LIVING IN THEIR CARS.
I LOVE HOW THE MEDIA ARE JUST
DYING TO SAY SOMETHING POSITIVE
ABOUT JOE, OH, MY GOODNESS, HE
HAD A GOOD WEEK.
HE PASSED SOMETHING OTHER THAN
GAS.
SERIOUSLY EXPECT THEM TO SAY OH,
HE MADE A BOOM BOOM WHEN HE
FLUSHED.
IT'S SO PATHETIC.
AND ANYTHING POSSIBLE NOT TO SAY
SOMETHING NICE EVEN WHEN HE
PASSES A HISTORIC FOREIGN POLICY
BILL.
THE PROBLEM IS THE SPENDING IS
BASICALLY NOW WE'RE JUST
BASICALLY TRIMMING OUT DOLLARS
AND IT MAKES SENSE, BECAUSE WE
HAVE AN INCREDIBLE SHRINKING
PRESIDENT WITH AN INCREDIBLE
SHRINKING DOLLAR.
IT'S A RACE TO SEE WHO BECOMES
MOLECULAR.
AT THIS POINT YOU COULD PROBABLY
FOLD UP JOE AND PUT THEM IN
CONGRESS HIS WALLET.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE DID NOT
MENTION THEN I THOUGHT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT WAS WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING ABOUT THEIR
RACES, INSTEAD OF ACTUALLY
TRYING TO IMPROVE THEIR PARTY,
THEY ARE MEDDLING WITH THE
REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: WE WILL GET TO THAT
LATER IN THE SHOW.
I'M TRYING TO KEEP YOU ON YOUR
TOES, GREG.
>> Greg: IT MAKES ME TALLER.
>> Jesse: ANYTHING TO HELP.
KATIE WE HAVE THIS BIG PAYOFF IN
WEST VIRGINIA, SO HE IS
SATISFIED THEY ARE, BUT ARE
DEMOCRATS GOING TO BE REALLY
EXCITED BY THE SPENDING ON THE
CLIMATE AND THE WEATHER?
SO MUCH SO THEY WILL STOP THE
RED WAVE FROM HAPPENING?
>> Katie: YOUR TONGUE ABOUT
THE BIG COMEBACK?
SO JOE BIDEN ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL IS NOWHERE TO BE SEEN, AND
NOT BECAUSE HE HAS COVID, HE IS
ISOLATING IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT HIM
ANYWHERE NEAR THEIR CAMPAIGN,
MOST UNPOPULAR SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
ABOUT TO LOSE THE HOUSE AND HE
ALSO HAS OVERSEEN THE HIGHEST
INFLATION INCREASE SINCE THE
1970s.
INFLATION IS A PACKED, SO WHEN
JOE MANCHIN TRIES TO SEE THE
BILL EVEN THOUGH IT DOES NOT
RAID'S TAXES, BUT IT DOES.
JOE BIDEN HAS A 1.9% TAX ON
AMERICANS TO INFLATION.
>> Jesse: BUT YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND, THIS IS THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
>> Katie: WHICH IS A TOTAL
LIE, AND JOE MANCHIN IS GETTING
A PIPELINE, SOMETHING THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE
GREEN LIGHTING REGARDLESS OF
GETTING A SPENDING PACKAGE AND
RETURN, AND THEY ARE NOT DOING
THAT.
THE MONEY THAT IS IN THE PACKAGE
FOR THE GREEN LOBBY WHICH IS A
HARASSMENT OF HIS HOUSE WHICH IS
A HOUSEBOAT IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THEY ARE GETTING A BUNCH OF
MONEY FROM THE CHINESE SOLAR
PANELS TO BRING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
SO AGAIN, WEST VIRGINIA IS THE
FIFTH POOREST STATE IN THE
COUNTRY, THIS IS AN INFLATIONARY
BILL THAT WILL MAKE
JOE MANCHIN'S CONSTITUENTS AND
PUT THEM IN A MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT POSITION FINANCIALLY
AND INFLATION WILL GET WORSE AS
A RESULT, SO YES AGAINST THE
PIPELINE, BUT THEY WILL PAY A
LOT MORE FOR EVERYTHING THAT
THEY NEED ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> Jesse: SO JESSICA, LET'S
JUST SAY A YEAR FROM NOW SOME
DEMOCRAT GETS UP THERE AND THEY
SAY, WELL, WE SPENT ALL THIS
MONEY AND THEN THEY ARE GOING TO
SAY ON WHAT?
WE SPENT IT ON GREEN, AND THEN
CAN THEY POINT TO ANYTHING,
WELL, WE DID THIS, THERE IS NO
SOLAR PANEL AND NO WINDMILL?
WILL THEY POINT TO ANYTHING?
THEY HAVE NOT BUILT ANY OF THESE
CHARGING STATIONS A YEAR LATER.
>> Jessica: WHERE YOU LOOKING?
>> Jesse: EVERYWHERE, THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE EVERYWHERE.
>> Jessica: SO JESSE WATTERS
THINKS THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
FEELING, OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY MAY BE BETTER AND THEY
ARE TANGIBLE BENEFITS FOR
EVERYDAY AMERICANS IN THE BILL
WHERE THEY SAY OH, I HAVE MY
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE INCREASE
FOR ANOTHER YEAR WITH THE
OBAMACARE SUBSIDY AND MIGHT SEE
THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS
NEGOTIATING OUR OWN PRICES IS A
BIG DEAL.
>> Jesse: ABOUT PAYING OFF THE
INSURANCE COMPANY IS
$100 BILLION, THAT'S A SUBSIDY.
I'M SORRY I DON'T WANT TO
INTERRUPT YOU, I'VE BEEN
INTERRUPTING TOO MUCH.
YOU CONTINUE.
>> Greg: FINALLY.
>> Jessica: SO I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY IS RAISING THE TAXES
POINT, SO THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
TAXATION WAS A ONE ORGANIZATION
THAT SAID THAT, AND THEY DID NOT
SAY THAT, THEY SAID IT WOULD
LOWER INFLATION, THERE IS
SOMEBODY WHO GOES ON THE JOINT
COMMITTEE AND TAXATION IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY MODEL WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU RAISE THE CORPORATE
TAX RATE, SO THEY CHANGE THE
MODEL IN 2013 TO SHIFTED FROM
YOU ARE LOOKING AT ME LIKE YOU
ARE BORED, BUT IT IS RELEVANT.
THAT IS THE REPORT WE ARE
CITING.
SO THEY USED TO SAY THAT
SHAREHOLDERS WOULD JUST ABSORB
ALL OF THE BURN FROM THAT WHEN
YOU WOULD RAISE THAT, THEY
CHANGE THAT IN 2013 DID SAY THAT
IT WOULD SEE PAST THE
SHAREHOLDERS AND WOULD AFFECT
EVERYBODY ELSE, BUT THAT'S JUST
A MODEL OF CONSUMPTION, IT'S NOT
A TAX BILL.
JOE MANCHIN IS TELLING THE
TRUTH, I SEE YOU SHAKING YOUR
HEAD, BUT THE ONLY THING THAT
CHANGES IS THAT 15% CORPORATE
TAX RATE ON FIRMS OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS AND THE HEIGHT OF
HYPOCRISY THAT EIGHT DAYS AGO OR
WHATEVER IT WAS IF YOU TALK
ABOUT JOE MANCHIN EVERY
REPUBLICAN WOULD SAY HE IS
SAVING AMERICA, HE IS THE ONLY
SANE PERSON AND TODAY HE IS AN
IDIOT WHO GOT DUPED.
>> Jesse: HE DID NOT GET
DUPED, HE GOT BRIBED BY A
PIPELINE.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF A
RECESSION WHEN A REPUBLICAN
SENATOR IS LIVING OUT OF HIS
CAR.
KENNEDY, YOUR RESPONSE.
>> Kennedy: HE IS PUSHED BACK
ON HIS OWN PARTY SO OFTEN THAT
DEMOCRATS HATE JOE MANCHIN.
I DON'T CARE WHAT PARTY THEY
ARE, I DON'T CARE WHAT STATE
THEY ARE FROM, THEY WANT TO BE
LIKED AND JOE MANCHIN HAS SAID
SO MUCH, HAS SAID NO TO SO MANY
THINGS THAT AT SOME POINT HE HAD
TO SAY YES.
HE HAD TO SAY SOMETHING AND I
THINK WHAT HE IS BETTING ON IS
HE WANTS TO LOOK LIKE THE HERO.
HE WANTS LIKE LIKE THE GUY THAT
IS PLAYING BALL, BECAUSE HE
KNOWS THAT KYRSTEN SINEMA IS
GOING TO BE A SENATOR NO, NO,
NO, BECAUSE SHE HAS NOT MADE HER
OPINION CLEAR AT THIS POINT AND
I THINK SHE WILL BE A HERO TO
ARIZONANS IF SHE PUSHES BACK ON
THIS.
THIS COULD BE HEARD TIME ONE.
AND KATIE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
INFLATION IS A TAX.
WHEN YOU HAVE A WAGE INCREASE OF
3% AND ARE PAYING 9% THAT IS
STILL A 6% GAP THAT MOST
AMERICANS CAN'T AFFORD RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ARE CLOSING LOOPHOLES WHICH
IS INCREASING TAXES ON PEOPLE
WHO ARE SINGLE AND CORPORATIONS.
THESE LOAN CORPORATIONS GETTING
CRUSHING AMERICANS --
>> Jessica: THEIR OWN HEDGE
FUND MANAGERS.
>> Kennedy: THAT IS THE OTHER
LOOPHOLE, THAT'S COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT SINGLE ENTITY
TAX THROUGH CORPORATIONS WHICH
WILL GET HOSED THROUGH THIS AND
NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT THAT,
BUT MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
AMERICAN BUSINESSES OPERATE THIS
WAY AND IT'S THE ONLY WAY THEY
CAN SURVIVE BY HAVING A LIST OF
DEDUCTIONS THAT THEY WRITE OFF
SO THAT THEY CAN KEEP THEIR
BUSINESSES RUNNING AND THEIR
FAMILIES FED.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT,